okay so today we're going to talk about
Mersenne numbers so we have to pick one
of our Mersenne numbers to it exemplify
the category now Brady always makes me
do this so I've decided to pick 31
because by the time you watch this video
I will be 31 so it's a nice personal
number for me so 31 is our example of a
Mersenne prime
so a Mersenne prime is a prime number to
begin with like 31 31 is a prime number
a prime number is as you probably know a
number that can only be divided by 1 and
itself
the first few prime numbers are 2 3 5 7
31 is a prime number but it's a special
type of prime number because it's one
less than a power of 2 what are the
powers of 2 you've got to you've got
fourth you've got 8 16 32 and so on okay
so that's just 2 times 2 times 2 times 2
times 2 that's the sort of thing
none of these are prime numbers but
let's have a look at one less well 1 now
if I'm not honest we don't say 1 is
prime there's a special reason for that
let's have a look at the others 3 is a
prime number and it's one less than the
power of 2 so that counts as a Mersenne
prime 7 is a prime number and it's one
less than a power of 2 fantastic 15 now
that's not a prime number so that does
not count and 31 there you go that was
our example of a Mersenne Prime now
there aren't many of these Mersenne
Prime's in fact there's only 47 Mersenne
Prime's now they start off as 3 7 31 the
next one after that is a hundred and
twenty-seven so let's have a look at the
next couple powers of 2 64 128 and well
this is 63 and that's not prime but this
is 127 that is prime so it's one of our
Mersenne primes
they're called Mersenne Prime's because
they're named after a French
mathematician called Marin Mersenne who
was a monk a mathematician and a
musician and a fan of alliteration his
favorite cartoon was Mighty Mouse his
favorite film was Mad Max so he was in
contact with a lot of other
mathematicians around the world and he
was trying to make a list of this
special type of prime number and that's
they named after him are they useful
they used for and I used by codebreakers
so they use to make better iPads or are
they just a game for smart
mathematicians later and well prime
numbers are obviously very useful to
mathematicians they're famous and
they're famous for a reason Mersenne
primes are a special type of prime
number something very special about
Mersenne primes they are related to the
perfect numbers we've talked about
perfect numbers before they were 628 496
8,000 128 they were known by the ancient
Greeks they were given this idea that
they were perfect unique Mersenne primes
and the perfect numbers are two sides of
the same coin let me show you why if I
pick a Mersenne prime let's call it 2 m4
Mersenne prime okay so M is our Mersenne
prime times it by n plus 1 divided by 2
and that will give you a perfect number
let me show you 3 times 4 divided by 2
that's 12 divided by 2 that's 6 that was
the first perfect number ok let's try
the next one 7 7 times 8 divided by 2
that's 56 divided by 2 that's 28 that's
the second perfect number 31 same thing
31 times 32 divided by 2 and that will
give you the third perfect number 4 9 6
and let's try 127 1 2 7 times 1 2 8 and
have it it's 8,000 128 two sides of the
same coin right so you can help defined
the next Mersenne prime it's called the
great internet Mersenne prime search a
great website with an unfortunate
acronym it's at Mersenne org and you can
try it yourself download the program it
uses collaborative computer power to
find the next Mersenne prime why why
should I do that why should anyone do
that for the glory for the glory
because mathematicians will thank you
for it like the perfect numbers we don't
know if there's infinitely many perfect
numbers we don't know there are
infinitely many Mersenne primes or not
so that's another open question
something that maybe you could work out
what's it going to take to work that out
hell hell will that question ever be
answered it's not going to be easy it's
not going to be obvious it's going to
take a different way of looking at
things coming at it from a different
angle something that other people
haven't tried yet maybe not your usual
school maths but something else whatever
it is something we haven't tried yet the
man or woman who does it what will what
will what will it mean for them if a man
or woman comes up with that proof what
what will happen if you do come up with
that proof you will have glory thrust
upon you you will be famous for coming
up with such a proof something that has
eluded mathematicians for hundreds of
years there's something you can have a
hunch about yeah I think technically we
would have to be Mersenne prime agnostic
but it's definitely something you have a
hunch for mathematics is done that way
people think mathematics is a dry
subject that it's logical but people
have intuition they have to pursue their
intuition so if you ask me I would say
yeah infinitely number of Mersenne
primes yeah I would think so I might be
wrong
you